three nanometer chips from Apple are
coming yes it is confirmed that they're
going into mass production as you see in
this article right here the only
question is which product is going to
get the three nanometer chips first now
the whole situation is a little bit
confusing but as I add more and more
puzzle pieces together it's starting to
become very clear and I am getting
extremely excited so let's dig right
into this as you can see we just got a
report from digitime saying that tsmc is
holding a celebration at the Fab 18
Factory on December 29th to Mark the
start of commercial production of chips
using three nanometer process technology
yes they are starting before the new
year and that only means that we're
going to be getting some products from
Apple and the reason I know this is
because intel was originally supposed to
be using tsmc's three nanometer chip
dies for their meteor Lake GPU type
aisle and that was way back on the 23rd
of November 2021 but look at this in
August They delayed their order causing
tsmc to slow down three nanometer chip
expansion but of course due to today's
report yes they are kicking into full
gear this week which is great news but
then even worse Intel ended up canceling
the three nanometer chip nodes for their
GPU and meteor Lake and delaying it
until the Aero Lake CPUs so this delay
is going to be even longer than we
thought because that's only going to be
launching in
2024 so of course these three nanometer
chips that tsmc is building right now
are not going to Intel at all so the
main question is which products or which
Apple products are likely to be the ones
that are going to come with these three
nanometer chips well we recently got a
report from Mark German the best apple
leaker out there saying that the all-new
Mac Pro is still in testing but the M2
extreme chip is likely canceled which is
of course really really bad news but
what this hints at is that the Mac Pro
is getting delayed even further maybe
even as late as summer or even later
because I had an interview with Mark
German on this channel and that's
exactly what he said he said we might
see it all the way as late as the summer
now on top of that a lot of people are
going to say that the new Apple VR
headset is going to be coming out early
next year with three nanometer chips
which I agree they are going to have
three nanometer chips but we did get a
report from Ninjago also a really
reliable leaker early this month saying
that the shipments are potentially
getting delayed until the second half of
2023 which means a January event
revealing the VR headset is likely not
going to happen and he even said this in
a tweet saying that the time frame
between the media event in January and
then shipping all the way in late 2023
is too long because people forget about
the product and it basically slows down
the hype so it's not going to be the VR
headset either and that only leaves one
thing yes the report that we just got
hints at these chips actually going
towards the M2 Pro and Max chips which
are going into the 14 and 16 inch
MacBook Pros and I know there's a lot of
confusion about this because due to
recent reports a lot of people thought
it would be five nanometer maybe just
maybe four nanometer but look at this
they're hinting at three nanometer M2
Pro and Max chips and those leaks and
rumors actually started way back then
over half a year ago in June of 2022 we
had reports that tsmc was starting mass
production of new three nanometer M2 Pro
chips later this year and that was from
Jeff poo but not only that we got
another one from taiwan's commercial
times once again saying three nanometer
M2 Pro chip for the MacBook Pro entering
production later this year which those
three nanometer chips just entered
production or they are this week so what
if we were right all along through all
these crazy leaks and rumors and delays
and everything going on recession what
if Apple actually is giving us three
nanometer M2 Pro and Max chips well
that's exactly what we are going to get
into right now showing off the rest of
the evidence check this out recently
December 18th Mark German said that new
Macbook Pro Models are going to be
launching an early 2023 which only
points at Apple's annual March event
which they almost always have one in
March and there's almost always Max at
that event and I think that's the exact
event that the new Macbook Pro is going
to be coming and then we also had this
report of two unreleased Macs spotted in
esteems data based December 10th and one
of those is a Mac with the M2 Max chip
which was already leaked which I'm going
to show you in a second and then an
undisclosed chip which I believe of
course is the M2 Pro and because we're
getting these leaks at this time it
shows is that these products are
shipping very soon and now let's get
into the benchmarks because we got some
awesome leaked M2 Max benchmarks and
they're actually really really good
check this out
2027 single core which means we're
finally over 2 000 this is gonna be a
really good Improvement and 14
888 for the multi-core which is decent
it's not that great it's not what I
expected but it's still a decent
Improvement but the shocking thing in
these benchmarks is that the clock speed
of the M2 Max chip was
3.68 gigahertz and that is a lot because
right now the M2 Chip is only around 3.5
3.49 and this is a jump above and it's
interesting because the entire M1 family
was stuck at the same 3.2 gigahertz but
this time around it looks like the M2 is
going to be different from the M2 Max
and that actually hints at the
technology being different as well and
the thing that interested me the most is
that the brand new a16 bionic chip built
on the four nanometer chip process from
tsmc which some thought would be coming
to the M2 Pro and Max chips it only runs
at
3.46 gigahertz essentially pretty close
to 3.5 but these new benchmarks are
showing 3.68 which is a further
Improvement hinting at potential three
nanometer chip technology now the last
thing I want to mention and get into is
a very interesting report that we've
recently had about the iPhone 14 pro and
its a16 chip if you watched my recent
video that I made about it you'll see
that the GPU has barely changed it's
essentially unchanged in real world
benchmarks and tests and that's because
they were planning for a Next Generation
GPU that's totally redesigned and much
faster but they ended up scrapping it
and going back to the old design which
is why we have barely any change at at
all so my thought is what if this brand
new GPU design got delayed but it's
still going to show up and the M2 Pro
and M2 Max and hopefully also on three
nanometers so I'm so happy that we just
got the support because it confirms that
tsmc is pumping out these chips and
they're pumping it out for a very
specific important product and as
Apple's other products are getting
delayed it only makes sense that they're
going to come into these new 14 and 16
inch MacBook Pro so if you completely
disagree with me let me know in the
comment section below or if you don't
want to wait for these new Macbook Pros
you might just want to buy an M2 MacBook
Air then check out the YouTube tagging
feature below thanks for watching and
click the circle about to subscribe for
more videos like this one see you in the
next video
[Music]
foreign